Let's talk about seven causes of cancer
you probably have never heard before.
And you probably also know that like
viruses could cause cancer, but there's
some other really interesting things
that can cause cancer that you need to
know about it. So, I'm going to go
through this list and then I want to
talk to you about the nature of cancer
and uh some real interesting things
about it that you need to know. So,
definitely watch this entire video.
Okay. Number one, inflammation in
general, especially if it's chronic in
nature, can activate uh cancer and even
make cells that are precancerous into a
full-blown cancer. It can even increase
the the malignancy of a cancer and even
drugs, medical drugs that inhibit
inflammation. Also, it can even come
from an overactive immune system. Also,
in inflammation, you have hypoxia. you
have a lack of oxygen in a certain area
and that also can activate cancer.
Number two, stress. Chronic stress can
initiate cancer. There's someone that
that I'm very close to recently uh that
got rid of their cancer but uh went
through a stressful event and the cancer
came back. In fact, the first time the
person had cancer, they went through a
stressful event. So stress can activate
certain genetics that can increase the
risk of getting cancer. Chronic stress
activates cortisol that uh can paralyze
the immune system. So it puts your
immune system in a state of, you know,
inactivity and then things can happen,
right? Part of the immune system is all
about killing off cancer cells as well
as viruses. So if you don't have that um
that defense mechanism, you you are more
susceptible to getting cancer. Number
three, loneliness can increase your risk
of getting cancer as well as social
isolation. There's been links to cancer.
Several studies have indicated this
especially for breast and colon cancer.
There was a study done on 9,000 women in
2012. And then in uh 2019, there was a
study done in 12,000 people over the age
of 50 that showed this association
between loneliness and cancer. In one uh
report that I read, it was comparable to
smoking and obesity as far as the risk
factors, which is very very interesting.
So you can imagine if someone is
isolated or they're very lonely, okay,
it's going to bring their emotions way,
way, way down and that definitely can
affect every single cell in their body,
especially the immune system. All right,
next one is bereiement. This is
grieving. This is a loss of someone, a
loved one. And um this can have a
devastating effect on your whole
physiology, including the immune system.
In 2016, there was a study done on a
loss of a spouse, increase in the risk
of lung cancer, colon cancer, pancreatic
cancer, and even skin cancer. Number
five is depression. The link between
having depression and increasing your
risk of getting cancer. In 2009, it
studied this uh connection and showed an
increased risk of getting cancer to the
lung, the colon, and the rectum. So
depression also related to these other
things like a loss of a loved one.
You're going to get depressed. And when
you're depressed, there's probably a lot
of stress going on too that's causing
the depression. And then let's talk
about number six. Lack of sleep
increases your risk of getting cancer.
Even going from 7 hours to 6 hours, that
loss of 1 hour can increase the risk of
getting certain types of cancer. Now, of
course, a lack of sleep also can
increase stress and cortisol. If you
think about it, what is one function of
cortisol? It's an anti-inflammatory.
That's why they give it to people like
predinazone, for example, for all types
of inflammation. Well, here's my
question. If you're going through all
this stress, shouldn't stress, because
it increases cortisol get rid of your
inflammation and make you painfree and
inflammation free? Well, this also
relates to another video I did on
insulin and insulin resistance. When you
have high levels of insulin for a period
of time, you downgrade the receptors to
the point where it doesn't work anymore.
So the key word is chronic. Chronic
activation of cortisol creates a
cortisol deficiency. So when you have
inflammation from stress, you're lacking
cortisol in the receptors. And this is
why they have to give you cortisone
shots or you have to take prennazone,
which I don't recommend. But the point
is this, chronic is kind of the key
word. A little bit of stress is actually
good for us. A little bit inflammation
is fine, part of the healing process.
But when you have chronic inflammation,
okay, chronic stress, chronic depression
over a long period of time, that's when
things become a problem. Now, number
seven, EMF, electromagnetic fields. This
thing on your next to your head. Okay,
talking about your computer, power
cables. I mean, EMF is classified as a
possible carcinogen to humans. Now, you
might be countering that by saying,
"Well, wait a second. If that's so true,
why don't they talk about this in the
news? Why don't they recommend that we
avoid it?" Do you realize how much money
is involved in this? This is probably
the next tobacco situation. Um, it took
years before they acknowledged that
tobacco is bad. I predict years from now
they're going to also talk about how EMF
create a lot of problems. And my initial
introduction to EMF was when I was doing
seminars for all the governmental
agencies and I went into the National
Science Institute and talked to one of
the uh researchers there and he was the
one who brought up did you know the link
between EMF and brain tumors and and
brain cancer in children. I'm like no.
He says yeah look it up. Interesting. So
anyways, I'm bringing that up to point
out that you should start to use your
phone at a distance with the speaker or
have some type of ear device that
doesn't draw a current right into your
brain and um start looking at this EMF
situation because it is a problem
especially for adults and teenagers that
are just constantly on their cell phone
247. Now let me just talk a little bit
about cancer because this is really
really important. They've been studying
this theory about how cancer is caused
by mutated genes for a very very long
time. Okay? And this model has funded a
tremendous amount of research but with
very very little success. I'm talking
about using chemo, radiation, and
surgery. The outcome from those three
therapies is almost insignificant. It's
it's marginal. They're looking at it
from surrogate end points. What does
that mean? How much the tumor shrinks,
but that does not relate directly to
outcomes like survival outcomes. Why?
Because of the toxicity involved in
shrinking the tumor. Now, I'm not
denying that there's not genetic
mutations involved, but based on a
tremendous amount of research, the
mutations that are developed are
downstream. Okay, that happens after the
cancer has started. In other words, the
mutations are secondary. There's
something else that occurs first. Okay,
that initiates the cancer. And this work
was initiated by Dr. Otto Warberg and
also done presently by Dr. Frederick
Seaffrey. And both of those doctors
isolated the location of the cancer is
not in the gene. If it was, we would
have had a cure for it long ago. The
location of cancer originates in the
mitochondria. That's the energy factory
of the cell. What's really, really
interesting about this is an experiment
that has been done over and over and
over again. If you take healthy DNA from
a healthy cell and you put it into a
cancer cell and just inject it in there,
that healthy cell will convert over and
turn into cancer. If you take the DNA
from a cancer cell and you inject it
into a healthy cell where the
environment is healthy, you will not get
cancer. So this experiment basically
tells us that it's the environment that
dictates what happens, the environment
of that that gene. It's the lifestyle
that you live. It's the the things that
you're bathed in all day long. The genes
are secondary. They're not in the
driver's seat. And this is why all these
activators are such big factors. And
these are all things that you can do
something about, right? You can actively
and aggressively counter your stress by
exercising, by doing physical work, by
go walking into nature, by changing your
environment, by taking vitamin B1, uh
taking adaptogens like ashwagandha,
being in social environments, uh helping
others, uh donating, uh contributing,
all those things actually help reduce
stress. The other point about this is
that um the key word is chronic, right?
Chronic inflammation, chronic stress,
things like that. When we talk about
chronic inflammation,
um, that's usually activated by
something you're doing in your diet that
you're consuming too many omega-6 fatty
acids or you're doing too many refined
carbs and not enough omega3 like cod
liver oil. So, there's many things you
can do to counter this chronic
inflammatory situation. Like for
example, genetically, I have really bad
genes for inflammation. So, I have to
constantly make sure I don't overtrain.
constantly make sure I take enough cod
liver oil. I eat just the right foods. I
don't eat refined foods or greasy foods
from like hydrogenated oils and things
like that with trans fats. I have to
avoid all those. So, you have the power
to change your diet. Keep that in check.
actively and aggressively do things on a
regular basis to counter the stress that
life gives you, including not watching
the crazy news that's out there, as well
as hanging out with toxic people, being
on a diet that's not inflammatory, and
also start to be aware of your
environment to start looking at these
EMFs. There's a great little device that
you can get to measure your EMFs. This
is the one I use. It's called Trifield,
and this could measure EMFs. Um, this
one's simple to use. You just turn it on
and you can start bringing it close to
different devices around your
environment to see what is creating the
most um frequencies and then you can
change that very easily like I did. I
completely set up my computer very far
away from me. Um I always use my cell
phone from a a distance and I don't use
those um earbuds. U those are really
bad. Now, if you haven't seen my video
on EMF, okay, it's pretty interesting.
You should check it out. I put it up
right here.